what does warren buffett do
i think he actually has fun just doing
investing i know he does
not i think he loves the game i don't
think he's like wakeboarding on that go
go on here let's find out tony uh go go
on warren buffett's favorite hobby if
you go down there well you saw one go
back go back kai go back
top thing warren buffett's favorite
hobby reading while reading
under warren buffett's approach
investing it's a hobby that you
generally enjoy okay go back to the 25
things you don't know about warren
buffett let's see what
if we first stock he bought he was 11.
keep going
go up okay first talking about he was 11
years old he made 53 000
by the age of 16. by the way that's in a
different era
he was rejected by harvard business
school interesting okay keep going
see what number four is we're looking
for fun keep going
little faster guy he eats like a
six-year-old
he lived in the same house since 1958
his father-in-law told him cannot read
that guy
his father-in-law told him his
father-in-law told him he would fail
nice that's always a good motivator
people will pay millions to have lunch
with them
true somebody paid 4.57 million dollars
like a couple years ago
in 2013 buffett earned 37 million
dollars a day
rough nearly 94 of his wealth was earned
after he turned 60 big motivator never
give up keep going
wow number 10 uh uh he never tweeted
before he's never tweeted before that's
cool keep going
uh 11 buffett owns 20 suits but has
never paid for any he steals
him he spends 80 percent of his day
reading fantastic
uh buffett will give an employee a
million dollars every year for the rest
of his life
his or her life if they can guess the
ncaa sweet 16 teams that's pretty fast
there's a hobby right there he likes
march madness that's right that's a good
point that's a good thing right there he
ditched his flip phone for an iphone in
2020 20
20. he takes a dozen kids to dairy queen
every sunday
i said no that's cool buffett rarely
emails okay
keep going 17 he plays
ukulele buffett pledged to donate 85
percent of his berkshire berkshire
hathaway stock to charitable foundations
okay
he was the olympics he was the awarded
the presidential medal of freedom by
barack obama
out of all investing legends buffett has
the same best track record for beating
the market
impressive his face was on cherry coke
cans in china
in china okay he doesn't follow anyone
on twitter he's a big fan of breaking
bad
wow that's a good look keep going is
that him well what is that that's
actually him
that's actually the coolest picture born
i've ever seen that's actually coolest
picture
he likes to joke around okay we know
that he looks to a poem
when markets decline no one can tell you
when those will happen more than others
extraordinary opportunities if you can
keep your head when
all about you are losing theirs when all
about you are losing uh theirs
if you can wait and not be tired of
waiting if you can think and not make
thoughts your aim
if you can trust yourself when all men
doubt you yours
is the earth and everything that's in it
okay
all right cool do we have another one or
two can i can i make here's how your
mind can play tricks on you and your
eyes if you could
go back to that list kai go back to the
very bottom of it go back to number 25
take a quick glance at number 25 and
then look away i literally when i first
saw that i thought he looks to porn
i thought that's what it said he looks
important i'm going wally
this morning good for you i was saying
is that your business insider does their
stories they wait for number 25
so when tom zenner spent time with him
he noticed how much point he was
that's probably what his three i got to
tell you when i hung out with warren
buffett all we did was watch porn
that's all we did i can actually see you
doing that pat was wondering what he
does for fun
i don't know there we go okay all right
so yeah so we love you
we have planned to learn what's that he
plays bridge though
good for him he doesn't play back i mean
nothing makes you seem more out of touch
you hang out with in dominican too i
mean that's all you need to know
there's like 200 i feel like that's in
touch you're hanging with okay
so let's continue so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye